what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch Brooklyn Nine-Nine
the season 4 premiere after that incredible
Cliffhanger from season three ladies and
Gentlemen please leave a like and a comment about
anything you want I don't care what it is is
because it just helps out the video regardless
tell us why you ate this morning tell us about
your favorite animal that you once had tell us
about the love of your life tell us about the
woman or man that you missed out on that you
should have married instead of the one you're
with I don't care what it is just put it in the
comments also full interaction watch songs will
be single with your own copy of b99 over on our
patreon page thank you so much for all who have
shown your support and have joined us over
there yes super sexy rejects let's get to it
are you ready for this one Daddy's daughter Ann
is getting divorced Susan Berger Sue we know
the woman in the middle we should fix her up with
Bernice's son what's his name the doctor oh Vince
and he's not a doctor he's a pharmacist although
that might appeal to Anne you're such a cracker
it's a kid and who should we fix him up with
huh oh now Sal you know I'm still getting over
the tragic loss of my wife she was such a strong
female woman with nice heavy breasts oh that's
my neighbor hey Larry ah hey grab Greg ah that
was it grab not sure why I have so much trouble
remembering probably because our relationship is
so casual you've been a little depressed have I
don't need the burrito
you deserve this promotion without going
there and get it give them a hell Greg
yeah yeah good morning Carly Timmy looks
like you're keeping the machines running
smoothly whatever Carly will be the first to go
I'd like to be assistant manager
serious oh I just never expected you to
be interested in management I mean you
don't seem like the type of person who's really
interested in the leadership roles really what
I'm very hard working yeah when you're not totally
blazed I assure you that's not me okay tell that
to the account blanchula t-shirt that you were
rocking last week hello go to location one now
Maya Rudolph
I can't hear you can you hear me
I can't hear you I think my engine's too loud
I think we should talk at her okay has anyone
questioned your current identity either in
person or online no pop quiz Greg where did
you go to college Ohio State where I majored in
Communications uh Die Hard wrong Jake's
favorite movie is die hard I asked you
for Larry's favorite movie two people can
have the same favorite movie they can but
they don't Larry's favorite movie is Failure
to Launch oh no I'm sorry but it looks like
Larry and Greg will be in Florida indefinitely
Pop Quiz Larry who's a female lead and Failure
to Launch Sarah Jessica Sarah Jessica
Parker man it's like you want to die
you were right it's the job it keeps me focused
well good I'm glad to hear it yep now if you'll
excuse me I gotta drive this [__] back to work
right oh sorry this is the ikura [__] 5000.
ATVs are so fun I once flipped one over oh
okay Jimmy figgis where the hell are you
oh Larry
I am off Hong Kong I don't know where the horn is
yeah with the ATVs the only thing
you're selling is a huge pile of
bunk how did you get here so fast
you were walking I was power walk
after we met the Marshall you said something very
strange it was squirtingly wasn't
it no something much stranger right
I guess the combination on the first try
69 69 because I hate this stupid place and
I've got to get out I mean this town's claim
to fame is that its Mayors keep dying and no
one knows why that's insane snap out of it
and get a job okay I wonder who's hiring
hey everyone I just want to introduce you
to our new assistant manager Larry sherbert
no no way no I believe in the power
of nicknames smile face senorita swag
guys can I get real with you for one
sec I used to work for a real stickler
type of guy that just got off on telling me
what to do one time he invaded my private
space and stole my stuff why would he do that
perhaps he had a good reason wrong Mr Fart he
was a jerk and he sucked but he was the one who
motivated me to get off my ass and get this job
so in a way we really have him to thank for
all this happening give it up you have zero
experience I guess you lied on your resume Greg
you Stoney macaroni of course I lied up my resume
lives are a lie I straight up said I was
that guy who landed the plane on the Hudson
someone just volunteered to be djb day here at
the Fun Zone we live by one rule when it's your
birthday you are always cool parents and kids are
all the same watch as I do a dance to your name
Derek
Eric well then I guess it's time for your next
task you're gonna need to change into what
no every time a go-kart Drives By I want
you to scream and this is very important
miso corny you can ruin my job Larry but
that's not all I've got here in Florida
I've got a life I've got friends you sure
about that honestly Estelle oh no go right
now Larry that's my walking Booth I have to
get my file no you will never get them whoa
oh geez we got bigger problems this is gonna break
the internet you cannot put that on the internet
I was hoping that would happen there's no car
drivers are merciless you have to get that video
can we please just press pause on this fight and
work together yes on one condition you stay the
hell away from my walking group The Walking
group meant nothing to me that's even worse
what did you find that much the camera was behind
her look at her calf it's a tattoo of Jesus
punching Bin Laden in the nuts nice okay that's
the most common tattoo we give so these photos
tell us nothing actually you know what that's a
high school graduation right Dan Marino High class
of 2003. Marina hi home of the Dolphins I suspect
no pet detectives town was real you guys got Inked
or what no I already have a tattoo what where
why how when I will never talk about it again
me it's on his butt we're not cops anymore how
are we going to get access to those files easy
I walk in there dressed as an exterminator say I'm
from one two three Pest Removal secretaries like
never heard yet then I'm like listen Lassie it's
best to let me speak with your principal I hear
it I'm gonna drop the accent she takes me to see
the principal you walk in behind me and download
the file hey there I'm the Exterminator here for
the uh you're here for the snakes all right oh God
I found our suspect her name is
Jordan carveden and she lives on
Shula Lane how did the snake room where we'll go
Miss Carlton you don't know yeah I do I got you
on video looking like a couple of dumbasses I
don't care about you a great viral video like
that could fetch me 10 grand and do you know
what type of tanning bed I could get for that
kind of money a mid-range one not necessarily
your can is great as is you look like an
evenly stained dick all right dude keep it
in your pants like I get why you're into this and
I could see something going on with us later what
if we gave you the ten thousand dollars make
it 15 you got a deal Jesus meet us tonight at
the Fun Zone eight o'clock I will shoot her
don't worry I still have a few tricks up my
sleeve the only thing I need you to do I'm not
going to show you my tattoo come on just give
me a hint is it an antique boat is it a musket
is it me on a dragon fifteen thousand dollars
cash you just stuck a few twenties around a
bunch of corn dog coupons here's the phone
you're gonna have to catch me first oh my God
you really thought that would work this video
is going viral I'm gonna demand they send us to
different cities because I don't want you anywhere
near me I swapped the phones sorry bye Greg hey
he didn't know you swapped the phone lastly hold
13 on the mini golf course is missing so tell
all the players to just he became assistant
manager promotion damn Greg you are killing it as
assistant manager I mean having the idea to have
people come in at 9 00 a.m that has really helped
business yes that is when the sign says we're open
I need to talk to this particular associate
and apologize for saying he half-assed his
ATV sales technique well that's very nice but
I've moved on and I'm with customers so thanks
these machines are death traps if you purchase
one you will be maimed I've looked over what
you've got given your resources very impressive
but I know it'll take me months to find figures
but we'll find him faster if we work together
what if we don't find figures what are figures
finds US ah we post this video and use it to lure
figures down here making ourselves in debate and
once Vegas is here we take him down climb out of
America's steaming orifice and go home I like the
way you're thinking Greg it's hold Captain Raymond
oh [__] now come and get us figus not a doctor
oh Holt Night Rises it's going down going down
dude Amy Rosa Terry were hilarious dude let's
do Charles oh my God some of those gags of Charles
so good the B stories amongst them all yeah really
kind of overshadowed the a story with Holt it was
really crazy how Scully and Hitchcock like took
the lead this time I know and they actually got to
prove themselves as something Fearless moving like
I cried a little bit for the both of them I have
never been brought to such tears on a Brooklyn
Nine-Nine episode until now no and I can't
imagine ever being moved such as such like in
this way again you know he talks sincerely for one
minute I'm sorry I didn't mean to make a mockery
of this very emotional episode
featuring the entire cast of the show
are you gonna talk sincerely about this episode
John we have a very limited time yes I enjoyed
it quite a bit it's very nice to be back with
the Brooklyn nine nine times up John I missed it
in our Bible way too slow uh just channeling my
whole speed it up uh good speed up the talk and
it was funny and it was good to see yorma and uh
you know let's talk faster uh uh come on I gotta
stand on my inner coin okay Brooklyn Nine-Nine
uh really funny jokes uh some really great uh
you know like banter-based comedy some good site
gags with the ATV really like the walking group
um and uh Jorma tacon from The Lonely Island
always funny to see him and Andy Samberg you
know bouncing off each other him and uh and
Andre Brower bouncing off each other was
really funny as well and loved the uh you
know just reorientation of the story them
trying to make it work in Florida but then not
making it work in Florida and deciding to go
after figures instead plus we got Maya
Rudolph Cameo amazing what do you think
I think the exploration of an identity crisis
is something really profound and perhaps deeper
rooted and perhaps something of a reflection
of what the the writing staff is going through
oftentimes as artists in this field we feel like
and I say we because I'm encompassing John and I
as and that symptom and posture syndrome and you
know it's like sometimes you're walking through
life feeling like you've got to be something
you're not and oftentimes you end up settling
for less and having to compromise and also living
in a life of fear so I thought this episode was
actually quite powerful and how it portrayed
something that I think a lot of people can really
identify with because in a lot of ways most of us
are living in our own witness protection program
where we are hiding behind a veil of oh my God
yeah this is the job that I have this is what's
most important to me this is the career this
is the money this is about keeping it safe but
there's no such thing as Security in this world
that is a lie told to you by the corporate yeah
by the security companies who want your money it
is not secure so go out there and take chances
and put yourself out on the internet I think
I got a lot from this episode and I feel like
it's going to change my my life and the journey
that I go down now after this this is profound
and neither of us will ever be the same again no
you know I'm getting highlights it's the first
day of the rest of our lives you know I would
love to work at like a mini golf course or an
arcade though because I I love going to like Chuck
E cheese or Sherman Oaks Castle Park Sam I'm not a
big fan of Dave and Buster's I feel like that is
uh kind of a mockery of what the the essence and
the joy and Nostalgia element is it's it's like I
feel like people kind of go there to be adults and
hook up and I don't like it I I feel like now you
should go for the games and I think there's a big
part of Dave and Buster's that doesn't feel like
they're there for the actual games I feel like
they're there for the beer more than they are for
the games I've been there with groups of people
like that where they just sit around the table
drinking beer for like two hours barely touching
the games and that's a real turn off to me to me
it's more like this you know being a grown ass
man walking in there's a bunch of little kids and
I look like I don't belong that is the joy right
there that's actually a really serious sincere
thought that's true when I go there and I want
to play basketball I'm like this freaking 10 year
old Latino kids taking forever just just like come
on quit hogging the basketball game yeah I want
to play the basketball game it's more my eye line
where the basket is and then if you shove that kid
you look like the [__] yeah yeah and then these
groups of like 18 people all like let's play Mario
Kart racing again yeah like cheese like share it
share it you freaking weird High School prep white
boys stop it there are only three terminals you're
gonna be here all night let some of us play yeah
yeah and also you know you're playing mini golf
and you got those high schoolers who are just
like I'm gonna be like the wacky guy to make
the girls laugh stupid jackasses you gotta take
the game seriously I hit my ball into the water
it's embarrassing and when we walk in the water
oh how about I take a golf club to your head you
dumb 15 year old kid beat you to death right here
on discourse on this astro turf your blood will
be spilled yeah yeah you know it's not fair but
you know these are the struggles that we have to
endure we have to endure people yeah kids just
think they can do whatever they want in places
that are kid appropriate when really you know
they they should learn to get out of the way
for us adult folk you know we want to play Time
Crisis right now or skee ball or miniature golf
and some of us take the scoring very seriously
some of us are trying to improve our game our
putt game our our getting the ball between the
things on the windmill game without getting you
know hit and sometimes I want to get a good doll
prize too and that requires a lot of tickets yeah
so you know and oftentimes yeah do I end up
spending more money to try to win the tickets
than I would for me to just buy the actual item
that I'm trying to win of course usually four
times the amount of money but it's about earning
that that's right converting tickets into a prize
that is the reward system that every American
should be aiming for in order to succeed in life
so with that in mind I did think that this was
a delightful episode and I thought it was funny
and I'm excited for them to get back into you
the the routine of actually copping it out I
imagine next episode we'll go back to actual b99
see what the life is like uh but yeah this was
a fun episode fun episode overall that's right we
should go into witness protection I didn't find it
hilarious there were some hilarious moments it's
okay it's never hilarious adjusting to a New Life
no it's not and learning profound lessons about
yourself when I lived in Puerto Rico for a year
it was really tough when I realized that Logan
Paul is my next door neighbor wow and I was like
why'd he build the house that is only slightly
a few inches taller than mine and I felt like it
was to make a point it's a slight use specifically
and uh but you know saving money on taxes is nice
you know you get a real good tax break and I feel
like the people of Puerto Rico are really happy I
was there yes and they appreciate it so that Logan
Paul's there Bad Bunny I feel like I think they're
all very very happy that we were all there yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna be on the new Bad
Bunny album right jobs we help out the economy and
the lower and Working Class People of Puerto Rico
yeah so I I kind of want to move back I mean I
still got the property multiple properties I don't
even let people rent them out make sure everyone
anybody yet nobody trespasses yeah they are only
for your use if you should decide you ever want
to use that and tear down a whole neighborhood and
whatever some people gotta live on the streets or
find some shelter it's not my problem that's their
problem they should have bought needed property
they should have bought more houses when they
had the chance I know we're being lazy people in
Puerto Rico whatever you're called just make that
house Puerto Rico people Puerto Rico ho so yeah
I built a quite a full strip and uh it's glorious
and once a year I take vacations over there
just admire the quiet isolation of the island
every once in a while I hear some other people
like yum miles away just a crowd to noise
just like shut up I throw money at them oh really
that's really kind of you I oh it's it's about a
hundred dollars all in singles yeah yeah yeah and
you make them fight over those singles yeah for
your amusement yeah and they don't really fight
because they don't really they're corn and then
they don't see the value in fighting over one
dollars however uh that's all I'm willing to get
they should see the value in fighting over I need
to pay for my property right I mean that's that's
the American dream and you pay for my house it's
just like Goring somebody over over a Washington
but you let me know people of Puerto Rico what
I can do to contribute to the community but I
will not leave uh my my home stays I won't leave
won't throw more money real rejects businesses
registered there too yeah good tax breaks yeah get
an offshore offshore accounts Greg Alba LLC also
registered there too Greg Corp Greg Corp yeah it's
great savings let's do a patreon Maria Hammond
Maria we want to shout you out because I
was thinking if I had to go into the witness
protection program who would I want to be my
neighbor it would definitely be you absolutely
because you are the most generous out of anyone
our patreon if we need something anything I
know you are one knock away hell I might even
just need to stand on my front lawn and be like
iced tea I know you would do it Maria so that's
why I would love for you to in case you missed
what we were talking about a little bit ago
I would love for you to live next to me in
Puerto Rico yeah come on down so if you and I
can just staycation together in Puerto Rico oh
man imagine the fun we would have we'd be up all
night together watching Rick and Morty playing it
on multiple televisions taking up the electricity
of the entire entire I don't know what it is a
a nation a a capital A a country country really
Puerto Rico is a country you know it's an Avenue
no it's a wonderful man this is crazy American
Property sanity Insanity America is a country
everything else is a small town so yeah everything
else is America adjacent they're they're just want
to be America anyway look that's awesome subject
here Maria you be the perfect neighbor because
also you know if I'm having like a really hard
night and I'm feeling emotional I know I could
just wake you up literally you probably just
let me walk in your door and be like hey Maria H
wake up drop some water on your face and I
know you would respond positively because
your love for us is unconditional get an
air horn really hard that's how we would
wake you up really hard to find someone
who would be as loyal and compassionate
of the neighbor as you surely it'd actually be fun
to live with you we could have an animal farm oh
cool buy some snakes feed some rabbits to them I
blame you for the guilt I feel over killing the
rabbits and you would take that guilt on because
you are that good of a name of a human being
you got soul and you're super bad
super bad can I say she's super bad
anyway Maria on a very sincere note um I hope
that you can have a positive holiday season
yeah and that this Halloween you could dress
up like the fish from the shape of water your
favorite costume only costs like 200 if in Puerto
Rico uh on silicone yeah but in uh in Americas
only people like John could afford it no
that's right and you can't borrow my shape
of water costume all right no it's fitted to
my specific body type not many people get the
Richard Jenkins costume but I was pretty
impressed with how you pulled it off I
love Richard Jane don't underestimate me we're
gonna get the fish outfit but you just you got
the suit the glasses the bald caps that's
right man and I was like he's doing it man
he looks like Richard Jenkins that's right man
call me the Jinx in fact if you just like hide
your hair yeah look at that Richard James
over here Richard Jenkins oh hey look at
me guys know Richard Jenkins did I just become
a much better actor all of a sudden hilarious
Republican activist that's right you guys
have no idea he loves he loves republicanism
he does he does have you seen his speech at the
White House correspondence you're right man oh
he's the funniest guy roasting bite and non-stop
hilarious Trump 2028 anyway Maria I hope you can
host the next White House Correspondents dinner
thank you guys for being here and uh thank you
Maria for being the best of them all every one
of them you're better than them all if any other
patrons are watching the shout out you strive
to be more like Maria you're the best around
you mean amount amount say Hammond Hammond you're
the best Hammond No One's Gonna ever break it down
or something else that rhymes I made the
shot weird we're done you made it weird